.
BRET: IT WAS UNSCHEDULED AND
UNSCRIPTED.
THE PRESS HAD TO SCRAMBLE TO
GET THESE SHOTS.
JUST AFTER 6:00 P.M. ON MAY 29,
1988 PRESIDENT RONALD REAGAN
AND FIRST LADY NANCY EMERGED
FROM THEIR LIMOUSINE IN THE
HISTORIC SECTION OF MOSCOW.
WORD THAT THE AMERICAN
PRESIDENT HAD COME OUT TO MEET
THEM UNANNOUNCED INSTANTLY
SPREAD, AND THOUSANDS OF
RUSSIANS SURGED ONTO THE
STREETS.
DESPITE A GROWING WORRY, THINGS
COULD SPIRAL OUT OF CONTROL,
THE 77-YEAR-OLD REAGAN ACTUALLY
CLIMBED ONTO A VEGETABLE CART
TO ADDRESS THE CROWD.
REAGAN'S PRESS SECRETARY MARLIN
FITZWATER THOUGHT THIS IS GOING
TO BE A DISASTER OR BE THE
GREATEST PERFORMANCE IN
HISTORY.
HELLO.
I'M BRET BAIER, WHAT THE SCENE
TURNED OUT TO BE WAS THE
DRAMATIC OPENING ACT OF A CLASH
OF IMAGES, WORDS AND IDEAS THAT
SIGNALED TO THE WORLD THAT THE
COLD WAR WAS ALL BUT ONE.
I WRITE ABOUT IT IN MY NEW
BOOK, "THREE DAYS IN MOSCOW,"
RONALD REAGAN AND THE FALL OF
THE SOVIET EMPIRE.
EPIC STORY WITH UNLIKELY HERO
OR SO IT ONCE SEEMED.
HARD TO BELIEVE BUT AS A YOUNG
MAN, THE GREATEST OF COLD
WARRIORS WAS SO LEFT WING, THE
FBI SUSPECTED HE WAS A
COMMUNIST.
IN 1946, COMMUNISTS AND THE
SCREEN ACTORS GUILD THREATENED
TO END REAGAN'S ACTING CAREER
BY POURING ACID ON HIS FACE.
REAGAN BEGAN TO TAKE NOTICE OF
COMMUNIST EXPANSION OVERSEAS.
>> WE IN AMERICA HAVE MET SOME
YEARS AGO A SIMILAR PROGRAM
CALLED PRESSIONISM UNDER THE
KAISER WEEK MET IT MORE
RECENTLY UNDER NAZISM UNDER
HITLER AND THE NATIONAL
EXPANSION OF RUSSIA.
BRET: FOR THE NEXT 40 YEARS HE
WAS RELENTLESS.
>> WE MET THE COMMUNIST
CHALLENGE DEPENDS ON YOU.
BRET: NO CRITIC WAS FORCEFUL,
MORE UNCOMPROMISING THAN
REAGAN.
SECURITY, OUR FREEDOM FROM THE
THREAT OF THE BOMB.
BY COMMITTING IMMORALITY SO
GREAT AS SAYING TO A BILLION
HUMAN BEINGS NOW ENSLAVED
BEHIND THE IRON CURTAIN, GIVE
UP DREAMS OF FREEDOM BECAUSE TO
SAVE OUR OWN SKINS.
BRET: IN THE 70s HE OPPOSED THE
NIXON-FORD-KISSINGER POLICY OF
DETENTE.
>> MY VIEW OF DETENTE IS ONE OF
MAKING CONCESSIONS TO THE
SOVIETS.
WE GIVE THEM SOMETHING THEY
WANT VERY BADLY.
WE DON'T ASK ANYTHING IN
RETURN.
BRET: NEITHER THE SUMMITS MORE
ARMS CONTROL TREATIES STOPPED
THE SPREAD OF COMMUNISM AS
AMERICA LOOKED TO BE SLOWLY
LOSING THE COLD WAR.
AFTER HIS LOSS TO GERALD FORD
IN 1976, REAGAN SPOKE MOVING
ABOUT THE STAKES.
NOT SIMPLY THE FUTURE OF
CIVILIZATION, THE SURVIVAL OF
CIVILIZATION.
>> SOMEONE ASKED ME TO WRITE A
LETTER FOR A TIME CAPSULE THAT
IS GOING TO BE OPENED IN LOS
ANGELES 100 YEARS FROM NOW.
I SAID TO MYSELF WE LIVE IN A
WORLD WHICH THE GREAT POWERS
HAVE AIMED AT EACH OTHER
HORRIBLE MISSILES OF
DESTRUCTION THAT CAN IN A
MATTER OF MINUTES ARRIVE IN
EACH OTHER'S COUNTRY AND
DESTROY.
THOSE WHO WOULD READ THIS
LETTER 100 YEARS FROM NOW, WILL
KNOW WHETHER THOSE MISSILES
WERE FIRED.
THEY WILL KNOW WHETHER WE MET
OUR CHALLENGE?
BRET: FORD HIMSELF LOST TO
JIMMY CARTER WHILE THE SOVIETS
ADDED SATELLITE STATES IN ASIA,
AFRICA AND SOUTH AMERICA.
[CHEERS]
WHEN REAGAN RAN AGAIN IN 1980,
HIS ANTI-COMMUNISM SEEMED TO
MANY OUT OF STEP WITH THE
TIMES.
BUT HE WON IN A LANDSLIDE.
USING HIS FIRST PRESS
CONFERENCE AS PRESIDENT TO,
AGAIN, DENOUNCE COMMUNISM.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, WHAT DO YOU
SEE AS THE LONG RANGE
INTENTIONS OF THE SOVIET UNION.
>> I KNOW OF NO LEADER OF THE
SOVIET UNION THAT HAS NOT MORE
THAN ONE REPEATED THEIR
DETERMINATION THAT THEIR GOAL
MUST BE THE PROMOTION OF WORLD
REVOLUTION AND A ONE WORLD,
SOCIALIST OR COMMUNIST, STATE.
BRET: AN ASSASSINATION ATTEMPT
INTENSIFIED HIS ZEAL, NOT
MERELY TO FIGHT THE COLD WAR,
BUT TO WIN IT.
HE AND POPE JOHN PAUL II WHO
MIRACULOUSLY SURVIVED AN
ASSASSIN'S BULLET SIX WEEKS
AFTER REAGAN AGREED THAT GOD
SPARED THEM SO THEY COULD END
COMMUNISM AND COLLAPSE THE
SOVIET UNION.
>> WON'T CONTAIN COMMUNISM, IT
WILL TRANSCEND COMMUNISM.
>> WHEN I CAME IN IN 1982,
REAGAN WAS STILL IN FULL
THROATED DENUNCIATION OF THE
SOVIET UNION.
HE WAS STILL VERY MUCH PLAYING
THE COLD WARRIOR.
>> WHAT I'M STRIKE NOW IS A
PLAN TO HOPE FOR THE LONG TERM,
THE MARCH OF FREEDOM AND
DEMOCRACY THAT WILL LEAVE
MARXISM AND LENINISM.
BRET: THE COLD WAR WAS
WINNABLE.
>> THERE WAS A HUGE ARGUMENT
WITHIN THE ADMINISTRATION.
PEOPLE IN THE DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT AND THE CIA BOTH
THOUGHT THE SOVIET UNION WAS
THERE AT THE TIME.
WE'RE HERE, THEY'RE THERE,
THAT'S LIFE.
GET ALONG.
>> THE AMERICAN PUBLIC SEEMED
TO AGREE, NEARLY THREE QUARTERS
FAVORED A NUCLEAR FREEZE BY THE
UNITED STATES AND SOVIET UNION.
>> I URGE YOU TO BEWARE THE
TEMPTATION OF PRIDE, THE
TEMPTATION OF BLITHELY,
DECLARING YOURSELF ABOVE IT
ALL.
BRET: THAT SPARKED REAGAN'S
MOST FORCEFUL CRITICISM EVER OF
THE SOVIET UNION.
>> TO IGNORE THE FACTS OF
HISTORY AND AGGRESSIVE IMPULSES
OF EVIL EMPIRE.
TO CALL THE ARMS RACE A GIANT
UNDERSTANDING AND THERE BY
REMOVE YOURSELF FROM THE
STRUGGLE BETWEEN RIGHT AND
WRONG AND GOOD AND EVIL.
>> I WAS AT THE SPEECH WHERE HE
TALKED ABOUT THE EVIL EMPIRE
AND FOCUS OF EVIL IN THE MODERN
WORLD.
>> IT WAS STUNNING, EVEN BY
REAGAN'S STANDARDS THAT WAS
PRETTY BLUNT AND PRETTY RAW.
>> I REMEMBER JUST ASKING
MYSELF AND MY STAFF SAY, YOU
KNOW, WHAT DID REAGAN HAVE IN
MIND WHEN HE CALLED THEM THE
EVIL EMPIRE?
IT WAS A PRETTY BRAZEN
STATEMENT FOR A PRESIDENT TO
MAKE ABOUT ANOTHER COUNTRY.
AND WE JUST DECIDED THAT HE
REALLY FELT HE COULD MAKE
THINGS BETTER.
>> RONALD REAGAN WANTED TO WIN
THE COLD WAR FROM THE BEGINNING
OF HIS TIME IN OFFICE TO THE
END.
>> YOU ONCE CALLED HIM A
PRINCIPLED PRAGMATIST WHOSE
STRONGEST SUIT IS KNOWING WHAT
HE BELIEVED AND WHY HE BELIEVED
IT.
>> HE HAD A SYSTEM OF GOING
ABOUT THINGS.
NUMBER ONE, BE REALISTIC.
NUMBER TWO, BE STRONG.
NOT JUST MILITARY STRENGTH,
ECONOMIC STRENGTH, BUT THEN
MORE THAN THAT.
HAVE STRENGTH AND PURPOSE.
NUMBER THREE, FIGURE OUT WHAT
IT IS THAT YOU WANT.
WHEN YOU GET ALL THAT STRAIGHT.
SIT DOWN AND NEGOTIATE AND YOU
HAVE A HAND TO PLAY.
BRET: BUT BEFORE REAGAN WAS
READY TO PLAY THAT HAND, HE